it's pretty awesome no one can mess with
us starting quarterbacks anymore sure
right yeah
out of the way Vaughn it's a quarter
best game now god I hate those pretty
boys Brooke wait up in here during the
purge it's dangerous out there they're
celebrating with hip thrusts oh my god
he's mimicking a weapon and he's wearing
fun cleats to play and not just as a
pregame warmup this is anarchy we need
to get some at Ryan's panic room the
real purge it's mental okay no purges
perjure the perchick goes through up
here okay great
okay thanks for that you must love the
Paris contest
what's the purge Baker I got purged
here's a tree an extra long episode of
gridiron I've told you this neighborhood
rules check down to be safe check down
old I don't think I can keep up with you
Saul well yeah from up there well I
guess there's still the wild card it
purges my cheat day sorry I'm to sack
you no that's okay great Zack great job
being set JJ look I'm having a good
season oh hey Jerry the money is all
mine now good job now bring me more
heads boys are you doing this to us
don't you see all the good to purchase
it lets the defense get out their
aggressions so during the season we have
record scoring colleague I must cleanse
myself of a quarterback every year Oh
oh you were my best friend I'm so far
the NFC is mine what do we do listen
sometimes you're tied to the chair
sometimes a chain you're not as good at
poker pieces as you think you are
[Music]
subscribe to this channel and rot your
brain with more episodes YouTube it's a
distraction coach Coach coach quit coach
coach hey wait coach coach goes